hey what's up guys my name is echeno
welcome back to the game engine series
today we're actually going to start
finally looking at some kind of
integration
with scripting but don't get too excited
because we're not going to start looking
at c
sharp or other languages we're going to
start right here within
c plus last time we talked about camera
systems check out that video if you
haven't already and today
as i mentioned we're going to be all
about the c-plus plus scripting so let's
start a little bit
with talking how we're talking about
how we're going to deal with cbos plus
as a scripting language and what that
even means and to demonstrate this a
little bit more we're going to
transition into the source code
and i'm going to just show a little bit
more about
um what we're actually going to do here
so at the moment
if we take a look at our game and i
might launch this it's technically an
editor but we still have some kind of
game related features in there
i think the biggest thing that we need
to uh the biggest thing that prompted me
to move on from the camera stuff to
the scripting stuff as well it's worth
noting is
the camera system and the fact that
we need a way to control the camera but
how do we do that without
actually you know hard coding it i guess
or creating like an orthographic camera
control class like we've
already got we have no way to move this
we've got components that make this up
we've got two different cameras and all
of that's great we can control
the two different cameras and it looks
great we can switch between them
however i want to be able to move the
camera so
with like wasd or the arrow keys how do
i achieve that
well currently if we take a look at our
code and how it's laid out we need to
probably manually do that inside the
editor layer but that's not
right because even though the editor
layer and this is
i don't want to get too much into this
but technically speaking if it's an
editor camera
you probably would write it like say
outside of the games runtime obviously
and
outside of the entity component system
and outside of all that stuff
but when it comes to the actual run time
camera so say that you're making a game
and you want to have a camera entity
that obviously responds to some kind of
behavior so for example maybe it always
follows
the player you want it to be part of the
entity component system it has the
camera component
which we talked about and developed like
in over the last few episodes
but now we need a way to actually hook
in some kind of behavior
into this camera entity and that's where
this whole
c plus scripting is going to come in now
this is something that is moderately
complicated and it's actually something
that i've developed over the course of a
live stream i've been live streaming
this stuff on twitch lately
there'll be a link in the description
below tuition tv for slash the channel
there's also a schedule there and if you
want to catch any of the live streams
they are there as well as the vods so
the kind of
recorded videos the videos on demand
that you can go back and watch so if you
want to see the whole planning process
of how this works
check out twitch they only stay there
for two weeks unfortunately just the way
the twitch stores them so i will make
them accessible too
or buy patreons as well so if you want
to really catch the whole archive of
them there's like one
total video at the moment then check out
patreon.com and help support
this series and you'll get access to all
of that but basically the reason i'm
saying that is because
long story short you know i have this
has been planned over
a while with the stream so what i'm
going to get into today is more or less
the
solution that we all kind of agreed upon
and all the ideas that i gathered from
stream because i was
originally going to do it a different
way and that's why i love you know this
whole streaming thing as well i think
coder2k
suggested that i take things in a
slightly different direction and i did
and the whole stream was supportive for
that
and so we decided to uh basically do
something a little bit better i think
than my original solution so i'm really
happy for that anyway
bit of a streaming disclaimer and also
i'm actually recording this
episode live on stream as you probably
saw from the chat in the beginning of
the episode so that's the new way
that we're going to be moving forward
with this game engine series
anyway without further ado let's talk
about how we would want to add
functionality
to this camera class and i'll try and
summarize
all of the iteration kind of that we
went through when we wrote this
in the stream and i'll kind of integrate
it into the current version of hazel as
well
so the way that you would the way that
you would probably expect this to work
is i want to be able to collect to
create a class such as camera controller
and i'm just writing it here for now but
it doesn't really matter i want
uh basically the standard entity kind of
script
functions that you would expect such as
oncreate which is a function that we can
call
or rather a function that gets called
when this entity i can't
write anything when this entity actually
gets created so just like unity you know
pretty standard
on update which is a function that takes
in a time step i think we've actually
got a time step
so we can just take that in this is a
function that gets called whenever we
update uh well whenever our game scene
gets updated
and then all of the entities
subsequently get updated as well this
gets called
and then you know there's there's a lot
of other ones like there might be one
for like the destroying of entities
there might be one for like on awake or
something if you want to
uh maybe create them first but then
actually like awake them a bit later
there could be like collision callbacks
there's a lot of stuff
we're going to focus on these three here
today so with these three functions
and this is by the way exactly how you
would expect this to work in c sharp as
well so you can probably see some
some similar some similarities here i
mean it's exactly the same and that's
the whole point
but these are native scripts so they
work a little bit differently there's no
script
runtime sitting apart like on top of
this this is all directly
integrated with the c plus one source
code so it should definitely perform
faster
and this is always going to be an option
i think it's worth mentioning that the
reason
why we want to actually create this
whole c plus plus scripting in the first
place instead of just
blindly integrating or rather
straightaway integrating c
sharp because that's what we're going to
use for our scripting language instead
of just doing that which we could have
done
i'm not just doing a cpus first because
it's easier i'm doing it because it has
a function
but also because people have been asking
me hey
is hazel going to support scripting in c
plus plus
i really want that i don't know c sharp
or i don't use c
sharp or i don't like c sharp can i
still build games in c plus plus
and in my opinion the answer should be
yes so to make that a lot simpler than
having to modify engine code
to bypass the whole you have to have
c-sharp scripts thing
i want to also make native scripting a
thing and that's why we have this whole
sequel plus layer so because it is a
native script it has to differ from a
regular script
so what we're going to do is we're going
to into the second camera we're going to
add a component
called native script component
this is different from the script
component of the future
which is something that will be c sharp
well most likely i mean
it's going it's gonna definitely be c
sharp but we might also extend it with
lua in the future i don't know
for now it's going to be just the native
one and the c sharp one
so we're going to add a new component
into this second camera
and we need a way to provide this
component
with this camera controller class so i
mean
let's think about how we can do that
what we could do is
maybe like native script component is a
component that takes in some kind of
pointer
to an instance of an object so in other
words we could allocate camera
controller here i guess
and just pass it in like this right and
then assuming that it has these
functions which we would somehow need to
check
maybe it's like it inherits them from
like uh you know some kind of entity
maybe we have a scriptable entity
um or something like that here and then
these are virtual functions and they're
inherited from that that's something
that you could do that's probably a
simple solution
but we decided with a stream that we can
do better than that
because as you probably know virtual
functions require a dispatch to happen
so in other words
every time we actually call this
function it needs to look up in the v
table what the over overridden function
is if it's present and called that
that's an indirect function call
that's not the best for performance and
of course since this is a native script
we want it to be as close as possible to
to the actual function calls we don't
want any kind of indirection that's what
c sharp will end up doing anyway
so because of that what we're going to
do is we're going to use
some magic to basically determine and
bind
all of these functions into the native
script component that we add so that the
scene can then call
these functions directly without having
to go through the v
table and that's what today's episode is
going to be about
so how do we achieve this stuff and we
are we are still going to have it in
inherit from a superclass the reason for
this is there's not going to be any
virtual functions but the reason we
we want that is just to give access to
some other
useful functions so for example in the
oncreate function we might want to
retrieve the transform component
well the thing is if if this is
not a subclass of some kind of super
class if this does not derive from
scriptable entity
how exactly are we going to be able to
write this function
well we would somehow first of all need
this scene
as well as the entity id from within the
entity library or the ant library
that's gonna get a little bit
complicated maybe if we had the scene we
could do something like this but
then again we need the entity id the api
becomes very messy i really like the way
that it's
clean inside c sharp and inside an
engine such as unity
we still want to keep it like this and
that's why we have this
to begin with okay so i'm not going to
lie i do have some reference code
from this that i wrote during the stream
because then this is
mildly complicated and a little bit
finicky so i'm going to be referring to
that but in general
we should be good to go to start
implementing this stuff so
the first thing that i want to do is
talk about this native script component
and how we're going to be able to bind
to it
so to you know long story short here
we're not going to be providing any kind
of instance this is another
important thing that we need to think
about how exactly is
this instance going to come to be so we
don't want to allocate it here
we don't want it to be allocated during
the creation of you know our components
whatsoever when we hit play in the
editor
and our game actually starts we want to
start
instantiating these script classes like
camera controller
so what we need to actually do is
provide
this native script component with almost
like a blueprint we really just need to
provide
it if you think about it with a bunch of
lambdas or function pointers
that are going to call these appropriate
functions and then let the scene handle
that at the right time
we don't have any concept of play yet
right we don't have
any concept of runtime yet really and so
because of that like this is the editor
layer
because of that we're going to basically
simulate that today
but just know that there are some things
here that will be done a little bit
later
okay so to start this off what i want to
do is
uh talk about the ui here and in fact
let me just find
the place where i wrote this stuff
specifically
so the way that i made this work and the
api that we used was basically we had
this native script component
and then we added a function to it
called bind and
the reason is we can't really take in
like another i
i guess i could have made an overload or
like specifically like add
script here that that added the
scripting component
for you in fact this might be something
that we do this is fun i didn't explore
this during the stream but
we could we could write a function on
the entity class called ad native script
that would make this a little bit easier
but for now the way that it works is we
do second camera at component so entity
add component
native script component which we're
about to create and then
once we get that script component it
gets created we obviously get it back as
a reference
we can call dot bind and then the name
of the class we want to bind
with and that's it and the script
component and that bind function on the
script component takes care of the rest
so it's really really straightforward um
and that's it and so
basically this is the this is the whole
api of what you'll need to do
as part of your game or application
if you want to add a behavior
add a behavior class really to a entity
to an entity
so i think that's a really clean api and
i honestly really like it so
let's make it work so let's go to the
components class
so what we're going to need here is a
native
script component and so inside this
native script component
what we want is first of all a pointer
to the instance now this is not stuff
that you should create on your own in
fact the only way to use this class is
really by
just adding it so you go add component
native script component
and then use the bind function so i
might make this stuff private in the
future but basically what we want to
have is that scriptable
entity we still need to have a pointer
to it we're not going to be creating it
ourselves
it's going to be up to the same class to
create it when this actual script entity
gets
instantiated but we still need to have
this so i'll say a scriptable entity
uh instance equals null pointer we'll
have to make this class in a minute in
fact we'll probably take a look at
making that
now so this script entity and i'm not
sure where to make this
i think that the best place to make this
is probably going to be
inside the entity class um although it
might be
fair to let's see if we can add this
somewhere else so we have seen
entity because i'll add it here for now
maybe we'll add it into a different
class in the future so scriptable entity
so this all scripts should extend from
this class and so actually because we do
that we'll end up repeating the api a
lot i mean i am actually going to go
back and
add this uh as a def as a different
header file so scriptable entity
scriptable entity namespace
hazel we will include
what's going on today we can include
entity because we'll need to
what is going on today journal can't
write
anything journal is stumbling on the
keyboard all right
class scriptable entity um so this
includes entity
and the things that it will really have
is first of all it needs to actually
have an entity right
if it doesn't have an entity then it has
no way of interacting with
the scene or itself so if we want to
call something like get component we
obviously need to have an actual
hazel entity which as you should know by
now is an entity handle
as well as the actual scene pointer
really important stuff
i'm also going to make this a friend
of the class scene so by doing this i'm
just letting the scene class
access like the private
[Music]
members and functions and everything of
this class and then the cool thing is
over here i can add any functions that i
want every
scriptable entity to have so stuff like
the getcomponent function
so let's add that one in as an example
so we'll say
this is basically going to be a copy of
this isn't it
so we're going to basically copy this
it's just that instead of calling this
stuff
we're actually going to return m
entitygetcomponent
so it's really just a wrapper around
that stuff and you know i mean this
what's whoops what am i doing um and
this should just get like you know
inlined and optimized away of course by
the compiler
um when we actually compile this stuff
so that's what it looks like and now the
cool thing with that
is that um let's go into hazel.h
let's include scriptable entity here
maybe we'll put this into like a script
class folder in the future to make it a
little bit better but as you can see we
now have this
and i can now call code like this and i
should be able to get that stuff so
that's pretty cool
so now that we've got that if we go back
to the
components class we can take a look at
adding the rest of this native script
component so the big one of course
is the bind function so what this needs
to do is take in a type
taking a class and then just figure out
how do i call the existing function so
how do i call the oncreate function
how do i call the on update function how
do i call the ondestroy function
so of course since it needs to take in a
type we'll make this a template because
it needs to be
needs to basically be able to bind to
anything and then over here
we need to set up a few functions so
we're going to use lambdas for that now
they're they are going to be stored
inside an
std function so let's just for example
take the oncreate function
so this is the oncreate function so to
do that we basically need to say that
the oncreate function is going to
um to call the uncreate function it's
worth noting that we obviously need the
instance so if we go back to here
let's let's take a look at this so how
do we call on create well we need to
have a camera controller instance
and then if we have an instance we can
just call you know instance
pointer whatever arrow on create and
that's it so to do that
if we take a look at this if we just
create a quick lambda i mean we need to
need to somehow get the instance and
then call on create
right and that should work so instance
is up here
how do we capture that well we could
take it in by value or by reference
we're going to take it in by reference
because it's really important this isn't
going to be set at this point at all
so we need to actually bind to this on
by reference
actually hold on i don't think we need
to do this at all no because what's
going to happen
is it's actually going to be passed in
as a parameter
so we'll say scriptable entity pointer
instance
and then we're just going to call
instance oncreate now hold your horses
scriptable entity doesn't have an
oncreate function
right if we did it like we could add
that and we could make it virtual
and then we could make the camera
controller override it
but we're not trying to do that we're
not trying to have any virtual functions
here at all
no v table none of that we want to just
have
the function that's on this type so how
do we do that well we know this type
or rather we know instance is going to
be of this type
right i mean we might as well take in a
void pointer here it doesn't really
matter
because of the way that we're going to
control this we're going to know how
it's going to work but i'm not going to
take an avoid point just to keep this a
little bit more
safe i guess or safe looking
and then so over here what we need what
we really need to do is grab instance
and
cast it to a t pointer so now
instance is a t is a t pointer which in
this case
is going to be if we go back to editor
layer we know it's going to be camera
controller
and then when we create it of course we
will create it as a camera controller so
that
checks out and we just call on create
and that's it so check this out we have
oncreate
we can call it amazing so
first of all how does the instance get
instantiated well
to make that happen we actually also
need a function here that sets up
this instance so how do we make it
actually
uh create or instantiate our camera
controller class
or whatever our script class is so we'll
say instantiate
uh funk i'll call these funks just
because
oh maybe not you know what maybe not
we'll be all detailed here
so what is the instantiate function
going to do
well i'm going to have it be a capturing
lambda here that's going to actually
take in the reference of this instance
thing
right so we could write this out like
this if we wanted to um in fact i think
i will just to make sure that that's the
only thing we capture
um doesn't need any parameters and then
it's just going to set
instance equal to new t so
this is worth noting that it's only
going to work if our constructor here
is um how should we say this i do need a
semicolon here
um if the constructor has no parameters
if it does we'll have to forward those
parameters
typically you don't write constructors
at all right if you look at like
an example from unity when you create a
new c-sharp script
you don't write a constructor with a
bunch of parameters or at the
at the very least if you do that which
is a bit weird because maybe you use it
elsewhere i don't know whatever
you should probably have a default
constructor so that is a requirement
that we do enforce here
but again usually that's fine we also
need need a destroy function so you need
to be able to destroy this instance a
little bit later
so to do that we are going to add that
in i didn't actually add that during the
stream
um but destroy instance function i don't
know if there's an opposite of
instantiate
but basically destroy instance function
will just delete this
um and i guess you know if we wanted to
in debug mode
we can also so delete instance now
instance
needs to be of type t when we delete it
otherwise we'll have
some issues um so we just need to make
sure that we're actually passing that to
t
um and then uh you know just make sure
that the destructor of
our um you know camera controller class
in this case gets called just in case we
allocated memory this shouldn't happen
though that's the thing we're deleting
this because it's heap allocated and we
need to
but um you know we probably want to be a
little bit smarter about how we manage
memory that's a discussion
for another day but basically this
instance gets deleted
so we have uh this function as well i
think that's all we need to do
and again if we wanted to we could also
set instance to null pointer maybe only
in debug mode or something like that in
the future
just to make sure that that actually
works okay
cool on create let's create the two
other functions that we have
so we have ondestroy
and we have on update
so on destroy is also going to be a void
function here
um and it's just going to call
so we'll do ondestroy it's going to call
on destroy and then finally on update
and on update is going to
call on update but we also need the time
step so we need to take in float
ts here or rather time step ts over here
and i'm also going to mark this as
accepting a time step of course so these
are our functions
now one quick note i want to add is that
std function
we recently removed bind from the engine
because
bind actually std bind allocates memory
and it's a little bit
it's you shouldn't be using it std
function does not allocate any memory
um usually or at least in my testing it
hasn't
so i have yet to do additional extensive
testing to make sure that it's fine or
just maybe reading the source code would
be a good start
but as far as i'm aware this should not
allocate the lambda itself should not
allocate memory
even if it is capturing so that's also
worth noting std bind is the evil thing
that we didn't want to use not a city
function as far as i am aware
okay so uh and we have all these
functions fantastic
so now if we go to the um
editor layer and we uh have all this all
of this stuff
here first of all let's do a quick
compile control f7 just to compile this
one file make sure all of these
templates check out
of course they don't a lambda capture
must be available from enclosing
function
scope okay oh because we need to capture
this
in that case sorry so to make this
happen we need to kind of capture this
and then do this instance
but if you just leave an ampersand here
i think it should work because it should
figure that stuff
out for you automatically all right now
we have no
um
blah blah what's this so we're doing a
right right hand of buying lambda
there's no acceptable conversion from
this
um why is that the case it's a void
function
isn't it so as far as i'm aware
that should oh sorry um well
for this stuff it's not working
obviously because we need to actually
take in
a scriptable entity so these functions
these std functions obviously need to
take in a scriptable entity as a
parameter these two don't because they
just affect
instance um i think that's it
if yeah all right that's it um
[Music]
yeah of course like we could take in the
component if we really didn't want to
capturing lambda we could definitely
make it work we would just need to take
in
the component itself or a reference to
this pointer and then we could assign to
it
and in this case it could even be copied
so we could make this a parameter in the
future if we wanted to but i think
doing it this way at least for now is
fine okay so now that we've got that i
believe we can compile
our code and it should work great so
let's test it out or rather before we
test it out we should talk about
what this actually does because at the
moment it does nothing so the point of
this is we've now
binded these functions these functions
they're now bound to be inside
the component class right so in other
words this native script component now
holds references to all those functions
it can now call them
so what we need to do is we need to go
to the scene class
and we need to actually make them do
something so this is all about rendering
code
inside scene on update what we need is
the um so update scripts
we need some script updating code now
oncreate
should definitely happen this oncreate
function should definitely be called
when we create
and then destroy needs to be calling it
when we destroy but none of that stuff
happens yet
because we don't have a we don't have
this concept of
let's start the game now or the run time
has begun
we don't have that yet and as a result
of that there's no point in making that
do anything yet
so because of that we're going to
simulate it we're going to basically
iterate through
all of the entities that have that
native script component
and then if instance is set to null
we're going to run the instantiate
function which is going to
create it and then when we create it
that way we know that okay it exists now
now we can call the uh on update
function to actually update the entity
and i guess as part of it we'll also
call on create so to iterate through all
of our update scripts
via and of course we need to create a
view so i'll do this in a slightly
different way that's a little bit more
optimized instead of actually
writing auto view equals m registry view
i'm going to
take a view of just the native script
components
we can't use groups here because we're
just going through a single component
and then i'm actually going to write dot
each and then
this lets us provide a lambda that will
be called for each
of the entities that have a native
script component
so i'm going to add in the entity and i
think it needs the
actual native script component which
we'll call nsc
let's fill out the rest here and then
our goal here is
really just to as i mentioned see first
of all
if this whole like instance is null
or not so if it if it's null right if
that instance doesn't exist yet and
thank you visual studio
for ruining everything um if it doesn't
exist yet then we want to call that
instantiate and
visual uh intellisense is just not
helping at all so i'm gonna have to
see what it is this is obviously a void
function so it's like it doesn't have
any parameters we just call it like this
we should now have a valid instance and
we can definitely check that to make
sure it works but i don't think that's
necessary
um now we've got a valid instance we can
call the oncreate function
now notice that to call the oncreate
function because i decided not to write
it as a binding lambda which i i could
have obviously i could have just
done this and then that way we didn't
need this parameter but
we've decided to do it this way so i
need to pass in
nsc.instance like that and now the
oncreate function should get called
finally uh outside of this so every
frame
and every time like for as long as this
exists obviously i mean if it doesn't
it'll create it
which should happen on the first frame i
guess but then on the first frame
after it's created and also on every
subsequent frame
we want to obviously call the onupdate
function
and we want to pass in the instance as
well as the time step so instance
and ts is the time step and that's it
so now technically at the beginning of
each scene update
anything that any entity that has a
native script component
will have its create function and update
function called
and the update function being called
every frame obviously so to test this
out in a very easy way
let's just print out the time step
so time step ts and of course we'll
test out the um i
don't really care about this let's test
out the uh
let's just say on create we'll test out
the oncreate function
by just writing this okay let's hit f5
and let's see if this works no it
doesn't because
we have some oh yeah so what happened to
this this completely are we
did we i guess we didn't include this so
scriptable entity needs to be included
hopefully that will uh work out for us
although yeah because i don't think we
include the component header file inside
the other one so we should be okay
all right look at this so we have our
time step being printed
every frame and then hopefully the first
frame we have on create okay
so you can see that we're now able to
essentially write some scripting code
as easily as this pretty cool so
let's test this a little bit more
extensively let's try
and do what we wanted to do last time
which is basically make that camera move
so how can we make it so that maybe like
the wasd keys or whatever would move
this stuff so first of all
let's grab the transform component um we
can grab this
uh let's just keep this really simple
this code really simple for now let's
grab it inside the on
update function um so dot transform i
believe
is what we're looking for we'll take a
reference from that we now have
transform
and now since this is part of c plus
code right it's got the whole c plus
plus api that we have available to us
we can just write if input is key
pressed
uh let's make it the um
[Music]
the w key for example so if uh we'll
start with the a key
so we'll move we'll make it move left so
to move left we just need to say
transform
um so let's get the third column of the
matrix and
the first element of that column which
is the x translation
and we'll uh subtract it by some kind of
speed so we'll write float speed
maybe equals like five or something like
that
and we'll subtracted by speed times time
step so
um let's do that uh d
w s so um
d will make it move in the positive x
direction w will make a move
in the positive uh y direction
which is the first element of that third
column and sorry the first index which
is the second element of the third
column and then
s will make a move down okay i think
that's correct so remember we're
modifying the camera's transform this is
not the view matrix
this transform will be inverted to
create the view matrix and since
we're taking a reference of this we
should just be we don't need to assign
it back or do anything like that
this should just work so let's hit f5
and let's see if we have now added
behavior
to our camera class in which case that i
think would be
pretty cool let me unselect my console
and we crashed oh it was almost perfect
so
apparently it's saying that we don't oh
no no i forgot to do something extremely
important
so i'm actually glad that happened
because i was almost about to end the
episode
um obviously right now if we call get
component
it's going to try and get the component
from the entity but guess what the
entity has never
been set we need to actually set
the entity so how do we do that
in fact guys to be honest i don't
remember how we did that
oh we just we okay i see we just did it
in the satchel function
so to do that we're going to go back to
our scene class and then
inside the instantiate function over
here and there's a few different places
you could do this but now that we have
the instance
we can just basically before we call on
create
we can say instance m entity
equals entity just like that
except entity of course is the ant id so
we need more than that we also need
this because that's the scene pointer
and we should have a
an an entity and i'll try and actually
uh
make sure that it actually recognizes
that type and this will probably make a
little bit more sense to read as well
take two let's hit our five and let's
see what we get
so now we're now we're actually telling
our scriptable entity which entity
belongs to
all right does it work it does not i
don't see any update happening here at
at all this is not not going as smoothly
as i was hoping it would go
um i wonder why that's happening we're
still binding to it it's still calling
on update or at least it should be
um the only thing i can think of is that
this get component function
might not be working correctly
although i imagine it should be let's
try and debug this so let's hit um
[Music]
f5 here so if i press this this
uh transform is obviously oh
right of course i think it is working i
just forgot that
we're modifying the second camera so if
we click if we uncheck
camera a and we now take a look at this
you can see we are now able
to move our camera false alarm
everything's working fine
so there we go and then of course if we
wanted to add this to
the first camera or something like that
instead let's just grab camera entity
let's add this to the camera entity
instead suddenly we now should be able
to have that same behavior
on our first camera which should be
pretty cool so yep there you go now if i
uncheck that i can't move this camera
but i can move my first camera and that
is the basic way that we are going to be
able to add
scripting in c plus plus to our entities
now there's one thing that i want to
note and this is the kind of more
advanced part that we went into during
the stream and we will address this in
the next episode
because uh this took this took a while
anyway but um
essentially we have a bit of a problem
and that is that what if we don't
provide
all of the possible functions so for
example
what if i don't want like you know on
create on destroy do nothing i want to
keep my class really simple i just want
to do that
is that going to work and the answer is
well no because as you can see the
template does not compile correctly
because oncreate is not a member of this
so when it tries to actually
bind this function it can't because
oncreate is not a function that exists
on t
which is a camera controller so how do
we make it
maybe only bind the functions that exist
well there are a few ways to do this
and to be honest i'm not sure exactly
how many ways there are to do this
but the best way to solve this is via
some template meta programming where
basically
we can check to see the type traits of
this t-class
and see whether or not this function
exists and then if it doesn't exist we
can use a
if const expert we can use a little
constant expression here to at compile
time decide to just not even compile
this oncreate function code whatsoever
if
the oncreate function was not provided
and then of course inside scene
we need to check to see if this function
exists and if it does exist we can call
it and same with the on update function
so we can check to see
hey is on has on updated function been
set and if so
call it otherwise don't so that is
something that we will tackle next time
because it's
it definitely deserves an episode of its
own there's lots of
fancy template code that needs to be
written there but otherwise if we just
leave our on create and on destroy
functions like this
then i think we should be pretty okay
so let's check this out yep everything
works alright guys hope you enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget
to hit the like button uh below and if
you're watching this on twitch don't
forget to follow the stream you can also
help support
this series and me and everything that
i'm doing by going to patreon.com for
slash the channel where you'll get
access
to some fancy benefits such as as i
mentioned these streams
recorded in kind of an archive format
that you can go through as well as the
source code to hazeldev
which is a much more advanced version of
this with like 3d rendering and like
you know c-sharp scripting and and like
a real editor and all that stuff if that
is something you're
interested in anyway thank you guys for
watching i will see you next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you